on social media a video of another
racist attack on black migrants in
Tunisia such attacks are prohibited by
law but rights groups say they're
condoned by the country's president last
week
said quote hordes of sub-Saharan
Africans were changing the demographic
makeup of the country sparking racist
attacks throughout the nation this is
what is left of one black woman's home
after it was ransacked black men and
women say they are arbitrarily rounded
up by police because of the color of
their skin
by the wall
because of ivorians and ghanaians are
now being repatriated some injured and
unable to walk after the beatings
people are scared to go out even those
that have the right paperwork and for
those that don't have visas they get
thrown out on the spot
many of them were hoping to make it to
Europe most African migrants from
Senegal and West Africa are not fleeing
War but poverty but Europeans don't want
them on their continent and have signed
agreements with North African countries
like Tunisia to stop them from crossing
the Mediterranean
according to Aid agencies they are 30 to
50 000 African migrants living in
Tunisia illegally Tunisian rights
activist Miriam mastur says they aren't
mistreated and do menial jobs that
tunisians don't want to do she says she
and her husband have also experienced
abuse so racism is has a long history in
Tunisia against black people even if
black people are like 10 or 15 percent
of the population now people in Tunisia
are in a social and economic crisis so
the the president uses black people as a
scapegoat
tunisians are out on the streets
denouncing the attacks holding signs
saying tunisians come in all colors it's
not only a reminder of the diversity of
the country but a call for Unity in the
face of growing bigotry and division
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar Senegal